we're going to begin with that massive
man hunt after yet another mass shooting
in this country another mass shooting
with a semi-automatic weapon police say
that a man in Cleveland Texas killed
five of his neighbors Friday night after
being asked to stop firing his weapon in
his front yard because the baby next
door was trying to sleep they say the
suspect 38-year-old Francisco oropesa is
armed and considered very dangerous he
could be anywhere at this point more
than two days after the shooting
occurred Janet shamlian is outside the
sheriff's office with the latest on all
this Janet I don't know what's wrong
with this country good morning
it's happened again Tony good morning to
you authorities believe somebody knows
where this suspect is and is now
offering an 80 thousand dollar reward
for his capture and this morning the
search is intensifying here more than
250 law enforcement officers from a
dozen agencies are combing a wide swath
of this region
a heartbreaking get-together as the
community of Cleveland remembered the
five people gunned down with an AR-15
style rifle hundreds of deputies and
detectives combed the region north of
Houston for the men police say went on a
deadly Rampage inside this home we do
not know where he is we don't have any
tips right now the attack happened
Friday night the sheriff says after a
neighbor asked the suspect to stop
shooting his gun in his yard so an
infant inside could fall asleep he says
it's his property he'll do whatever he
pleases on his property the man went
back in the house next thing they know
he's walking up the driveway with the
rifle in hand
s to Honduran foreign Ministry those
killed are Diana Velasquez Abdullah
Molina Jonathan casares Sonia Guzman and
nine-year-old Daniel Enrique lasso all
five are from Honduras five people died
in my county and that is where my heart
is
Wilson Garcia's wife and son were killed
in the attack
I don't have words to describe what
happened Garcia says his wife was on the
front porch when she was hit by the
gunfire
he went and shot her without saying a
word Garcia says then came inside to
find us all two other women were found
dead on top of surviving children
apparently shielding them from gunfire
Abdullah Molina's mom said her daughter
died protecting the lives of her
children
her daughter she says was a fighter
the suspect's phone and clothing were
found in a nearby wooded area but they
believed he is long gone from this area
they do think that the suspect has
contacted friends for help and are
hoping that large reward will encourage
someone to phone in a tip